caller and 607 what's your name where
are you calling from and what's on your
mind today hello this is Caleb from nook
Valley New York I have a question about
the Supreme Court yep
do you think that um Justice Kennedy
would retire and what do you think about
the thing about the Supreme I'm sorry
think about the travel ban in relation
to his retirement yeah yeah so I think
it's certainly been floated that Justice
Kennedy might be retiring whether the
timing will be what the timing will be
in relation to the travel ban hearing I
don't know Justice Kennedy is often sort
of like the swing vote in the in the
Supreme Court and as a result if you
anticipate a 5-4 decision on the travel
ban it's reasonable to suggest that
Kennedy could be the decision-maker he
could be the fifth in that however I
want to throw something else out there
which is that the Supreme Court hearing
on the travel ban may end up being
completely moot because remember that
the travel ban was a 90-day temporary
ban and those 90 days will have expired
by the time the Supreme Court is
actually set to discuss this so there is
some speculation that the Supreme Court
might say hey you know what this is moot
because this has expired
and that that's sort of it we'll take
we'll take up any subsequent case on its
merits if there's another band proposed
that is not a 90 day thing or whatever
the case may be
so you're thinking multi-dimensionally I
think that that's a good thing
but I don't know ultimately that the
timing of the travel ban hearing and
Justice Kennedy's retirement will will
swing whatever the results are okay yeah
all right thanks so much for the call
really appreciate it very very good to
hear from people with questions about
the Supreme Court